we all have regrets i have regrets
though i mean i know i
would never trade off where i'm at right
now to be somewhere else in my life or
in my
career i mean i have like i think one
thing i really struggle with we were
me and my wife were talking about it
recently and my mom having a
conversation all the time she's the one
that really pointed out
like i have imposter syndrome for sure
like i don't think i ever deserve
anything that i get or that like i
not you know worthy or i didn't work
hard enough for it or someone else
worked harder
was more talented so like that's
something i struggle with all the time
you know
um just being like okay with where i'm
at and feeling like
i worked i deserve it and
or earned it um but like i think that's
one thing that really makes me feel
lucky all the time is
i don't know how i got to where i'm at
like almost ever like even when i was
doing west side i mean i
should have been a junior in college at
the time and all my friends still were
and i was living all of our dreams and
like doing the broadway tour of west
side story like i
i caught every day was like why me man
like how
why why am i so lucky and i've kind of
every step of the way
felt like that i can tell you why
because that's the thing that's hard
because
when people's perception of you is
obviously different from the perception
you have of yourself obviously you know
i'm talented this and that but like i
look at you and i'm like he's a
good-looking guy
he's really talented but all that aside
the best trait about you
from just knowing you and i think which
is the most important with anybody is
who they are as a person people see that
and if it translates
they want to be around you they they
like you know you're very likable that's
i mean that's that's a huge thing
i always tell the story of uh james gunn
told me this story
and he directed guardians of the galaxy
and so in guardian galaxy 2
kurt russell they uh kurt russell was
telling the story about escape from new
york
and the director john carpenter was like
you know
i don't know they just want me to make
the character of snake pliskin more
likable
that kurt russell plays and he goes why
i'm likable i'm just a likable guy and i
think that's
true and so i think that's kind of like
is it your have you ever had those
moments you're like
i don't know the i don't know barry
seems kind of like a dick right now too
much of like a
like you know barry's a dick called todd
i mean
he's pretty freaky yeah
you know so you can relate today but
you're innately a likable dude i'm sure
you could play a dick and a weirdo you
could put an eye patch on and kill
somebody in a movie and people like that
guy's an [ __ ]
but there's something innately likable
about you
and i think it's humble for you to say
that you know uh you know do i deserve
this there's a lot of other actors i've
done that some
my whole problem is i never fit in i've
never felt
like i fit in i feel uncomfortable
around a lot of celebrities
i put on an air of like look at me i'm
confident i'm
you know and i could turn that on but me
too but the reality is is i'm always
kind of going oh [ __ ]
because you want to be liked you want to
be accepted that's i've talked about
that do you have you ever dealt with uh
you know anxiety in your life any kind
of depression or any kind of like yeah
yeah
i i've since i mean really young i mean
since probably four or five i've dealt
with like
anxiety depression like i've had real i
had really
weird anxious type dreams as like a
really young kid
and um i mean it's i don't want to get
too into it but like we we
before we got married we started doing
couples therapy just to like
you know be ready for marriage before
there was really nothing going on in the
marriage and then all kinds of things
for both of us start to like
come to the surface and as good persons
and couple and like as individuals and
all kinds of i mean i i was i knew i had
always dealt with anxiety but
putting like you know getting pinpointed
ideas about
where things started and why you're
feeling that way i mean anxiety is
ever present in my life for sure
you